this is where the ghosts of the past
rest in warsaw
the streets of what was the jewish
ghetto yet here they're confronting war
once more of course
situation not everybody wants to want to
be
made visible they're jittery
these are ukrainians living in poland
orchestrating their own war effort
they're constantly gathering information
to work out where best to send aid and
what's most in need
there's almost a feeling of a wartime
bunker not military but humanitarian
from this room thousands of refugees
have been found somewhere to stay
we definitely see our activities here as
you know
you know as part of the same
despite the same struggle but we're also
kind of sending a message that yeah
we're with you
even some refugees who fled from the
russian invasion are doing what they can
here
until a few weeks ago eve and christina
were students in kiev now they're
waiting for foreign fighters at the
airport i did not want to be the refugee
because
luckily
yeah unfortunately it happens in my
country but
i still might be useful
they don't want to say how many fighters
have arrived but point out two men
ex-military who've landed from georgia
and brazil
just waiting for people who want to help
our country and then you help them to go
on to ukraine yes
how does that make you feel that you're
doing that
really good we we know that we maybe
have
some special mission
sergey's mission was to drive from spain
where he works as a boxing trainer to
deliver aid then take refugees back with
him i'm from ukraine i have all of my
family in ukraine and i think
while the ukrainian about all the world
they must help each other
and ukrainians living in poland have
been returning to the country of their
birth to fight
it's not something everyone can do but
others are finding ways to make their
own contribution in a war
nobody asked for lisa holland sky news
warsaw